Transcription: Mandy Vincent
Relecteur: eric vautier
Quand j’étais petite,
je n’y pensais jamais.
Pourtant, ils étaient déjà là.
Fins et discrets.
Puis, ils sont devenus bien
plus visibles, bien plus présents.
D’abord peu nombreux,
j’ai vite eu l’impression
qu’ils étaient des milliers.
Noirs, épars, épais,
sur mes jambes, sous mes bras,
entre mes cuisses d’enfant.
Des poils,
des poils comme n’en avait pas
ma maman ou mes copines
ou n’importe quelle femme autour de moi.
Semblables à ceux de mon père
ou de mon frère.
Des poils d’homme, horribles.
D’où viennent-ils ?
Pourquoi en ai-je ?
C’est décidé, à peine
ces poils se montrent à moi
et déjà je les déteste.
Les autres se moquent, je dois les cacher.
En plein été, je suis toujours
en manches longues ou en pull.
Ma mère me dit que c’est normal,
que d’ici quelques années,
je pourrais les enlever,
comme elle le fait.
Elle dit que ce sont des poils d'enfant.
Mais je les déteste parce
que les autres n’en ont pas
ou ne montrent pas qu’elles en ont.
Comme beaucoup d'autres petites filles,
je ne veux pas me rendre à la piscine.
Je fais exprès d’écrire des faux mots
dans mon carnet de correspondance
ou j’oublie mon maillot de bain.
Une copine me confie raser les poils
de ses jambes avec le rasoir de sa mère.
Je vole celui que la mienne
laisse traîner sous la douche
mais ne sachant m’en servir,
je me coupe les doigts et les jambes.
Ma mère le découvre
et accepte à contrecœur
d’investir dans cire, crème
dépilatoire, épilateur électrique,
divers outils pour exterminer
ces poils si horribles.
Les premières fois,
ils résistent, ils s’accrochent,
et je pleure de désespoir.
Dans la salle de bain,
ma mère applique avec
une délicate maladresse
la cire chaude sous mes aisselles
en craignant qu’elle puisse me brûler.
Elle tente de l’enlever
mais n’osant me faire mal,
laisse des touffes de poils
recouvertes de cire.
Je crie.
Je lui demande de tirer plus fort.
Les bandes s’amoncellent sur le carrelage
mais les poils ne veulent pas
perdre la bataille
et il en reste toujours trop
pour que je sois satisfaite.
La peau est rouge, gonflée
et quelques poils résistants me narguent.
Voix des poils : « Tu ne nous auras pas,
on n’a pas prévu de partir.
On est bien ici. »
(Rires des poils)
Il me semble entendre leurs rires
pendant que ma mère tente de les prélever
avec une pince à épiler qui glisse
et n’arrive pas à les enlever.
Le lendemain, j’ai mal sous les bras
et je ne vais pas à la piscine.
Une fois de plus.
Mais je sais que je finirai par gagner
ce combat à force d'acharnement.
Eh oui, au fur et à mesure,
les poils deviennent plus conciliants,
s’arrachent plus facilement.
La douleur persiste
mais j’enlève mes pulls,
je remets des jupes
et je retourne à la piscine.
Je revis.
L’épilation devient
une routine hebdomadaire.
Jambes, aisselles et même maillot.
J'ai onze ans.
J'aime la sensation d'avoir la peau nue.
Je me sens belle.
Je ressemble à une femme,
à une vraie femme.
Ce récit que je viens de vous narrer n’est
pas une expérience personnelle unique.
Le hashtag #1ereFoisEpilation,
lancé par le collectif
Liberté, Pilosité, Sororité,
regroupe les témoignages
des premières épilations de femmes.
En voici quelques exemples.
Voix de femme : « J’avais onze ans,
on se moquait de moi
et de mes forêts sous les bras. »
Autre voix : « Je me suis épilée
pour la première fois en quatrième.
La douleur a été atroce.
Ma mère s’en est occupée
en me tenant les jambes. »
Et il en existe bien d’autres,
dans la majorité des cas,
la pression sociale autour de la pilosité
féminine déclenche l’envie de s’épiler.
Ce n'est que rarement un choix
personnel ou esthétique.
Et si ma mère et les femmes
autour de moi ne s’étaient pas épilées,
aurais-je eu honte de mes poils ?
Et si j’en avais vu
à la télévision ou au cinéma,
me serais-je épilée ?
Et vous toutes,
l’auriez-vous fait ?
Alors oui, en théorie, ça paraît simple.
Il est vrai que la pilosité féminine
n’est pas interdite par la loi
mais je vous assure
qu’il est extrêmement difficile
de faire le choix de laisser
ses poils à l’air libre.
Car a-t-on réellement le choix
quand à peine les bras levés,
les remarques fusent
et les ricanements ne se
font même pas discrets ?
Voix d’homme :
« T’as vu ses poils ? Dégueulasse. »
« Elle pourrait les cacher quand même. »
Quand une femme témoigne
sur les réseaux sociaux,
elle est moquée et critiquée.
Quand une femme affiche une photo
avec quelques poils qui dépassent,
ils sont affichés comme
la preuve d’un manque d’hygiène.
L’ancienne mannequin Mara Lafontan s’est
fait harceler sur les réseaux sociaux,
il y a à peine quelques mois de cela,
pour avoir posté une photo d’elle
avec quelques poils sur le ventre.
Alors dites-moi, comment peut-on
penser que nos poils sont normaux
si nous n’en voyons jamais ?
Dans les films, même dans
une société préhistorique,
dans un monde post-apocalyptique
ou sur une île déserte perdue
au milieu de l’océan,
les femmes sont toujours
étonnamment glabres.
Pensez-vous vraiment que dans
un monde où chacun tente de survivre,
où des extraterrestres et des zombies
peuvent surgir de
n’importe quel coin sombre,
les femmes dévalisent supermarchés,
maisons abandonnées
à la recherche de rasoirs
et bandes de cire ?
(Rires)
Alors que dans ces mêmes films,
les hommes ont souvent
une barbe, des cheveux mi-longs.
Où est la cohérence scénaristique ?
Pourquoi censure-t-on nos poils ?
Et surtout, comment peut-on
imaginer se trouver belle avec,
si nous n’en voyons jamais ?
Alors que j’ai pris la décision d’arrêter
de m’épiler il y a de nombreuses années,
il m’arrive encore de m’épiler lorsque
j’ai une baisse de confiance en moi.
Il m’arrive encore de regarder
mes poils et de les haïr
comme lorsque j’étais petite.
Pourtant, je ne regrette
en rien cette décision.
J'étais devenue obsédée par mes poils.
Je ne mettais pas de jupe si je n’étais
pas épilée au niveau des jambes.
Je n’acceptais pas de cunnilingus
sans être intégralement épilée au
niveau du pubis et des grosses lèvres.
Je mettais un pull
au moindre poil sous mes bras.
D’un autre côté,
j’avais des poils incarnés, des rougeurs
la peau de mes jambes était sèche.
J’enchaînais mycoses
et infections urinaires.
Et un jour, par simple défi,
sans être particulièrement militante ou
féministe comme je le suis aujourd’hui,
je décide d’arrêter de m’épiler.
Depuis ma première épilation
dans cette salle de bains,
je n’avais jamais
réellement revu mes poils.
Dès qu’ils atteignaient quelques
millimètres, ils étaient enlevés.
Là, ils poussent,
ils prennent leurs aises,
recouvrent peu à peu mes jambes,
l’intérieur de mes cuisses,
mon pubis, s’étendent sous mes aisselles.
Au début, je les regarde d'un mauvais œil.
J’ai l’impression qu’ils prennent
une place énorme sur mon corps,
qu’on ne voit qu’eux.
Je garde un rasoir et
un pot de cire prêts à l’emploi
En cas de besoin, les poils
peuvent disparaître à nouveau.
Mais je finis par m’habituer,
à apprécier les toucher,
à les trouver jolis.
Au bout de quelques mois,
ma peau est moins sèche.
Les boutons et rougeurs disparaissent.
Adieu mycoses et infections.
Et aussi, je bénéficie d’un gain de
temps et d’argent non négligeable.
Car, aujourd’hui, l’épilation est
devenue un véritable business
et qui ne concerne pas
uniquement les femmes.
Mais surtout la pression mentale
que je me mettais disparaît.
Je n’ai plus à me préoccuper
de mes poils en allant à un rencard,
en sortant boire un verre avec mes copines
ou juste en allant acheter
mon pain à la boulangerie.
Ils sont là, ils font partie de moi.
On catégorise les poils
de dégoûtants, pas hygiéniques
mais ils ne poussent pas sans raison.
En effet, ils filtrent les UV,
protègent des microbes et des poussières.
En 2018, sur France Inter,
le médecin Jean-Marc Bohbot
et la journaliste Rica Etienne
auteurs d’un livre
sur le microbiote vaginal,
soulignent l’importance des poils pubiens
pour limiter les infections
et lubrifier la peau.
« Les poils sont une barrière, »
disent-ils.
Mais pourtant on entend
souvent que les poils sont sales.
Alors oui,
ils retiennent parfois les odeurs
mais est-ce qu’ils ont
déjà empêché quelqu’un
de prendre une douche
ou de mettre du déodorant ?
Et surtout, pourquoi sont-ils
plus dégoûtants chez une femme
que chez un homme ?
Vous en connaissez beaucoup
des hommes à qui on a refusé
une relation sexuelle ou amoureuse
à cause de leurs poils ?
En revanche, on peut entendre
de nombreux témoignages de femmes
qui se sont fait humilier.
Voix d’homme : « Tu ressembles à
un homme avec tes poils sur les jambes. »
Voix d’homme : « Je te lèche pas
si tu gardes tes poils. »
Voix de femme :
« Avec tes poils, tu fais négligé.
Tu pourrais prendre soin
de toi quand même. »
Depuis quelques années,
un tournant semble cependant
être en train de se mettre en place.
Des collectifs se forment,
le challenge « Januhairy »
motive les femmes à ne pas s’épiler
durant le mois de janvier
et le « Maipoils » durant le mois de mai.
(Rires)
Oui, son nom l’indique.
Des livres et des webséries
remettent ce sujet au goût du jour.
Certains mouvements féministes
et particulièrement le body positive,
qui milite pour la réappropriation
par les femmes de leur corps,
et certains mouvements écologistes
qui prônent un retour au naturel
l’encouragent.
Mais ces quelques poils
restent en minorité.
Je vous propose maintenant
d'y faire attention.
Dans la rue, à la plage, à la télévision,
au cinéma, dans les publicités.
Où sont les poils féminins ?
Continuent-ils à se cacher ?
À être cachés ?
Je pense que
nous connaissons tous la réponse
et c’est pour ça que je vous en parle.
C’est pour leur donner de la visibilité
et vous dire simplement
qu’ils ne sont pas monstrueux.
Mon idée n’est pas de dire :
« Jetez vos rasoirs, vos pots de cire
et vos épilateurs électriques »,
mais de laisser
aux petites filles de demain
la possibilité de ne pas s’épiler
dès leur plus jeune âge,
d’avoir le choix de laisser
leurs poils à l’air libre
sans subir moqueries et humiliations.
Qu’elles puissent simplement se dire
que c’est normal pour une femme
d’avoir des poils.
Et que les femmes adultes puissent
avoir le choix de s’épiler ou non,
quand elles le souhaitent
sans être sans cesse critiquées.
Vous savez, il y a des femmes
qui s’épilent depuis un si jeune âge
qu’elles ne savent même pas
à quoi ressemblent leurs poils
au bout d’un ou deux mois de pousse.
Essayez.
Ils ne sont peut-être pas si laids que ça.
Ils sont peut-être même beaux
comme ceux de toutes ces femmes
qui ont accepté d’afficher leur photo.
Merci à elles, merci à vous.
Bonne soirée.
(Applaudissements)